so I'm going to talk tonight and I want
this to be informal so if you know don't
let your eyes glaze over right I mean if
you don't understand something stop me
and say I don't get it and then that
gives me the chance to either say okay
let's go into it or say well we'll talk
about that after the after the talk but
please don't you know don't just nod
your head like I'm looking for
engagement here and actually more
seriously we're my the company I work
with actually I'm working with a group
of companies and we're actually really
looking for engagement we're looking
both for people who want to verify the
ideas for themselves but also for people
who want to dig into the code the code
is completely open source and it's
currently being used on a couple of
commercial projects and we would really
like people to engage further we're also
engaging the academic community and
other sectors of the industry for
example we had a guy by the name of
David Jefferson who's a foremost expert
in electronic decision-making processes
like you know II voting and such give a
security review of our of our approach
in our architecture so we're really
looking for kind of a top-to-bottom
engagement you know from the
requirements to the bits and the bites
and I'm going to be talking about some
of the intermediate level stuff but the
stuff that makes contact with Scala and
hopefully you know for lucky we'll get
into some Scala code but I do have to
set the stage a little bit so
essentially the outline is really really
tiny i'm going to introduce a few verbs
and i'm going to attempt to motivate
those verbs in terms of an application
context the applications that I'll demo
are not the application context i'm
setting up here and that's because i'm
also using these slides that suspect for
my dev teams to try to get them on to
the next the next the next thing so i
have to solve multiple problems all at
once so i'm using this talk as an
opportunity to lay out some of those
ideas as well but but the applications
that i will
Mor very much along those along the same
lines this is just the kind of a
different skin for the same application
so after I introduced the application
context and a few verbs I'm going to
look at their implementation I'm going
to look at their implementation both
conceptually but also in terms of code
and hopefully the code will make some
sense it will be kind of natural for you
to understand and follow and then then
we'll actually look at a beat business
to business application that sort of
like LinkedIn where you don't have a
central entity that controls all the
compute and all the storage in all the
network so in this it's completely
decentralized people can businesses can
pick up their data and say you know what
we're going over here we're hosting over
here and and that's the application is
all fine with that and the same is going
to be true of the c2c application you
can think of it sort of like facebook
but with a distributed architecture so
there's no one centralized entity
there's no centralized compute no snow
centralized servers no centralized data
store and no centralized the assumptions
about network and bandwidth and then you
know I take a you know sort of wrap it
up with a summary and then take some
questions so let me let me move on at us
at a good pace here the verbs which I
hope you will find them very natural and
they all come from one single logical
principle which is what's called in in
logic the law of the excluded middle the
law the law of excluded middle says that
a proposition is either true or it's not
true now it turns out in computing
especially in Scala that law is not one
that is common in the data structures
that you work with or in the functional
setting normally you work with with a
slightly a variant of that in the
functional setting your
looking that not not a implies a but you
can't get a implies not not a whereas
the law of the excluded middle which is
true of classical so that's that that
that version is called intuitionistic
logic and that's what's in operation in
functional programming sort of in its
standard form classical logic which is
what we grow up with in high school
right that that has the implication
going in both ways so not not a implies
a and a implies not not a if you want to
understand the intuition intuitionistic
version one where you've only got only
got one direction think of a closure
property so you've got some set and
you've got some means of closing it up
so for example let's say you've just got
a volume but you haven't included the
boundary right so if you close which
when you include the boundary all right
well when you close if you do if you do
the closure twice you get just the
bounded entity right and that clearly
contains the volume but you don't have
it the other way the volume without the
boundary does not imply the closed
volume right so that that's a way to
think about how that that principle
might be the in the intuitionistic
version of the principal might be in
play here it's we have a very very
simple idea absolutely straight forward
the idea is if if you're looking for a
when you come looking for a I'm going to
grab your procedure I'm going to grab
your inquiry into a and if I don't have
a I'm going to store that inquiry away
right and then if a ever shows up I
promise to restart your inquiry when the
a arrives so that's how that's that's
the constructive interpretation of this
logical principle but but let's let's
let's hopefully hopefully that's
intriguing enough that you want to start
start digging into the concepts for me
that's if I can relate it to logic
becomes interesting so I'm going to I'm
going to illustrate this with a cartoon
let's begin with a cartoon let's imagine
that we begin with a really simple idea
of a key value based database okay and
if you recall we talked a little bit
about you know looking for a proposition
I begin my query for some proposition
and if I've got an a well then I can
hand it back there's my proof there's my
witness that I have an egg right so
you're looking at a particular location
and that location is the designation of
anus and and and that's the witness of
that of that proposition that's the
inhabitant for that type now if I don't
have this value sitting here what I'm
going to do is I'm whatever procedure
that you used to get to that location
I'm going to grab it and the way I'm
going to grab it is with scholars
delimited continuations so that's what
we do we put a reset and shift block
around your probe into the query and so
your probe is now reified as a
continuation I've got it and I can do
things with it like store it away so
what ends up happening there's there's a
kind of consistency in our database the
consistency is there are only three
possible states for a key value pair one
state is that that key does not exist in
the database another state is that the
key exists in which case there are only
two things that the value can be the
value can be a list of continuations
which are a record of all of those
inquiries that have probed that
proposition or there'll be as some data
and that's our that's our consistency
guarantee right that consistency
guarantee is derived directly from the
law of excluded middle so let's let's
try to put this I
dia to work okay so well how come how
can we put this tour well let's imagine
for fun that we're presenting tweets but
not tweets posts little micro blogs of a
variety of characters maybe maybe these
are too small but you might recognize
some of those characters there's there's
Martin at the top and Jason zog down at
the bottom and there's TR Crump's and a
whole cast of epfl and scala characters
right so so let's imagine that they all
have a view that's something like this
on their screen where instead of with
Twitter you know with Twitter and with
Facebook the streams from all the data
sources are interleaved so you see
exactly one column but we know from
literally hundreds of years of
information presentation that the the
human brain is really really good at
spotting temporal information if you
disentangle those streams of posts right
this is derived directly from musical
notation which has now had hundreds of
years literally hundreds of years of QA
right you can take ordinary kids and
within within a few short months of
training they can be reading scores
which give them multiple lines of
temporal information so let's see how
useful this is let's imagine that that
Martin here all he does is he posts an
event and if I hover over it with a
mouse right what I what I see is that
he's announcing that he's getting coffee
at some coffee cafe called ladro this is
one of my favorite shops in Seattle so
maybe the team is in Seattle for some
reason and what we get is a notification
that that it's five minutes from now so
this is this arrow pointing in that
direction means it's in the future if
the arrow we're pointing in the other
direction might be referring to an event
in the past and and the bar lines here
represent sort of
the tempo the passage of time right so
what we're looking at is maybe a
four-hour scope of time and then now
let's say another another character like
TR says you know he's headed to ladro in
two minutes and another character says
you know i'm headed to LA Joe in 10
minutes right and just with my eyes with
no other trip with no other training
whatsoever with my eyes I can spot guess
what they're all going to be at ladro
exactly the same time right so with the
correlation between select software and
more complications yes no okay most of
the room is not in their bed if you're
not come see me afterwards if this is
really going to stop you don't be brave
and say no I really want to get this now
okay okay so so essentially all consumer
all consumer variations of those furs
turn into for company geez and in
Special K right now I've been waiting
for the macro step to solidify
unfortunately it's not quite things are
not quite where I was hoping they were
going to eat with Scala still four
combinations are you sure your buddy
parser so what I really want to do what
I have right now is for whatever these
keys are I'll tell you what those keys
are I can compile those into a native
curry language of a variety of source so
we started with a sex because that was
easy to do in translation two of two
flower expressions direct correlation
and then we moved over to Marvel and
again the translation is relatively
straightforward the translation to give
a premise for for some of the top
translation to seek
is none other than dateable actually
using the basis of date above is the
core but the problem died facing did you
go look at that coat by the way we just
go to get up lighthouse is my name and
special k is the repo and I think
masteress is up to date you're welcome
to be looking at the code as we talk um
anyway so so I compile this directly to
a query in the native store and i would
like to also compile this but we can't
right now because i need scala to not
mess with the syntax I need this free a
certain compilation face so I'm still
kind of wrestling with that and you know
I began to talk about saying we get
engagement so if anyone wants to engage
on that talking us about some cool ideas
for persona end of the month I'm all
ears but essentially once this part is
going to be the continuation right it's
the thing to get to eat so this is
essentially lambda e handle e and this
lambda is only going to be called when
something lands in this collection of
that p okay so that's that's the basic
idea for all of the consumptive verbs
all right so you can put get here
subscribe here read here and all of
those verbs have a meaning in terms of
turning this e into a query the local
store and then and then checking if
there's nothing there because this is
actually secretly in a reset block we
have to continue
chip reset blog we have 2 continuation
available and if there's nothing there
we put the continuation there serialize
for the continuation ear instead of the
day okay so and then spin around we just
followed messaging style and so
collection dot for p value is what we
use for the producer verse right so so
here you would have publish put store
those of those birds yes oh I'm so glad
yes okay so now let me come clean about
what the keys are the keys are prolong
terms so how many people are familiar
with a prologue firm this one too okay
all right so you can think of it as
essentially a generalization of scala
case classes and patterns so week
without without much without much
Shwayze well with those waiting at all
every scholar Hayes class becomes a key
death ah that's another good question
from our point of view from special
casement of you the valley is ok we have
no clue what to do we leave that to the
application programmer so that if
they're very semantics is going to be
related to what's in the value position
then what must obtain the relation that
must obtain is that G is a view about
but we don't say what that means that's
absolutely up to the program that make
sense okay but you're touching on a very
very important idea which one gives you
just submit the pike archos news so the
keys prologue terms and I can give you
let's see you guys don't have my horsey
I'm a mathematician ur liked it lends a
scribble on white wolf all right well
maybe I'll just bring up a notepad in a
few minutes and we can scribble memory
so let me escape out of this and I just
want to bring out the translation of how
we do this others related to my card so
so now I've given you two constructs of
dsm right the for comprehension and the
book and i'm going to give you the rest
of ESL is that that visible ok so this
one it turns out i've got another
columns of the translation backwards for
your perspective there's not backwards
for mine so over here is the dsl we were
just looking at it is a very slim down
very good FPS oh ok so for some pattern
from supplication act a given key em run
this tandberg ok so that was the the
consumptive part and here's the
production part instead of doing the dot
her i just put it thank you ok no is
that is that visible turbulence if i
move the mouth ok alright so the bank
stands for put publish store those kinds
of groups the thing to the right is
actually a structured term for us its
key value and now we can do some cool
things we can spawn so we can ride with
you
in parallel and that's how we begin to
wire them up so you could for example
now that we know that this for
confirmation for response to this tiny
little expression here wait wait at this
collection for this look for something
for this key and run deep right or foot
at this collection at this key these
valleys those are the two basic forms
but now you like to like for them to
talk to each other in order for them to
talk to each other they need to be able
to run in parallel right so that's
that's how you acquire these two up once
you wear those two up and you have a
producer connecting to a consumer at a
given location and communication can
happen so that's equivalent to being
able to take the interpretation of key
and put it in its own thread take the
interpretation of Q and put it in tell
thread and left and run simultaneously
that's a single credit version I'll also
show you the distributed version minute
I need to be able to create new
locations and new collections I need
also to be able to have recursive
behavior so in Scala the recursive
behavior is so here here you can maybe
this is like the definition of a process
so i can find in the process exit
to some process body p here I can't
worry about the sub where you're too
much all it's doing is making sure your
definitions of our our expressions and
not declarations so I apply once I have
the definition I be a quiet to some
value so it's an expression like all the
rest of these it's just a notational
truth that's not a meal here the
corresponding thing is X becomes an
object its apply method become the body
is a climate that becomes the
interpretation of the body heat ok that
is remarkably tiny I can fit this whole
translation on one page if you go look
at a special day on a code base it'll do
fine download ranch I growth at this
little from pilot just to prove that the
combination technique works but a
general if I were to commit myself to
this this as a language that would mean
i would also have to make you'll know
mr. cell arithmetic here there's a
string manipulation right so i have to
take on the burden of all of that so
instead rather than taking on the burden
of maintaining a general-purpose
programming language which is a big deal
right well hi to is i use what kb he
does is we use an embedded dsl that's
invaded install it's based on this
translation right that is an
implementation of the verbs that we
talked about right and that means that
programmers can avail themselves of
almost allah and part of you know inside
the dsl constructs so white is little
easier than for me and hopefully for
them too sorry if you don't understand
speak now
okay we're moving on so now remember I
just talked about that I gave you the
single threaded urgent now here's here's
the distributed version so the kv DV
stack special case bag as a pledge avium
yes next night sphere sorry that there
ok cool so the KPD sack is a JDM act
together with the dsl of library
together with a cache along with some
physical search mechanism along with
some n QP provider so the two commercial
application is different working with
this is and this is rabbit so
let's look at the interpretation of just
one of those herbs right so the
application issues of get get plans and
KBB which checks the cash if the caches
up to snuff it's clean we just hand out
data let's say the cash is not clean the
next thing we do is we checked the store
ok now in the store doesn't contain any
day then what we do is we grab the
continuation at that moment and we store
the continuation in the value place or
the heat and then we do something else
has any acquaintances which is knows the
APAP provider the gift is forwarded over
to that node and now it's just to get
entering the system again so
now let's think about this a thing about
this situation if there was a foot at
the same key here and here what would
happen right two different idioms but
let's say just for fun that this one is
running at a data center in Tokyo and a
wake how about Paris this is running in
Paris inserting in London yeah okay so
so now another two other processes come
into play and one writes to Paris that
one rice in the same location is London
okay and we have continuations sitting
here and here oh and there is a piece of
information I'd like to tell you know
the continuation is that our store here
all I do is forward bias requesting
source that already now what will happen
so we have a right here a right here the
original request is sitting here stored
here and there's a there's a request
story do recorded back door to dairy
you'll get a race you see that okay so
let's say just just for the purposes of
discussion that the local one the local
right is service first so this
continuation is fired than that event is
handed up to that out page okay and um
this one fires comes back over here what
do we do all we do is write the data
location you know what happens
the data is constantly swimming around
the network there is no there's no
actual physical boundaries of the look
for the data unless you want her to be
in which basically continued but the
pristine form it's always swimming
around the network you know what that
results in the data swimmies to where
its most requested it automatically
Tunes to these each pads come on guys
this is cold yeah sure so so this one
doesn't the original request comes in
here right we don't we don't even want
to know who the earth originated and we
don't want to look at this this could
happen never hop-hop never pop right we
don't really want to know what the
applications advantages over here we
just want to get the data to Lord was
asking for right so instead of storing
some complicated procedure right which
is the application semantics which is
over here we just say hey give it back
to the requesting party so application
semantics has to happen a higher level
than just get input but remember you
have all of these birds with which to
slice and dice and makeup verification
we make no commitments or assumptions
about what is reasonable or watchful for
your application consistency the only
application consists the only data
storage consistency that we guarantee is
that in the database it will either be
data or a continuation that's the gift
doesn't entity and it costs of
performance you can affect eight I
wouldn't say performance that's a
different that's a different issue to be
a response time again that's not
necessarily the case right because if
the application like this in the case
that we're talking about let's go back
to the actual application case probably
they get to subscribe not a game in
which case the next data that comes in
when we fetch this up in the next a
little movie fetch the next day they
will be fetched again the point is
you're not providing application
Millicent manages that's what the act
we're providing a set of verbs that make
you more powerful and you're building an
ass yes yes so write some of the that's
exactly right if you look carefully at
the form of the dsl its collection oh
okay and then and really that collection
is is it's a slight of hand of a saying
collection in order to make it intuitive
but we're really talking about is an
entire KPD which can stand in fact for
an entire network of those that make
sense so when you go to a baby that
maybe he never has a web of
acquaintances yeah yeah that's that's
correct there will be there will be a
winner and a loser and the loser the
data or the loser swimmers away from the
losers location to the limit location
okay all very good questions now the
next step is how does this relate to
agents in internet so sorry I didn't
tell a little bit of a background also
you need to do timeshare and then we
started late so it's 2009 why don't we
expecting this to end it's a don't know
Tim 833 ok cool so then and I'll tell a
little a little sore just there's a
innovator down here at the Bay Area by
the name of hoopla homeland and he has a
company called innovation games he's
been looking in serious games in the
series play in a corporate sector for
well over a decade as a part of agile
methodology you guys have probably
played by a hooker those kinds of those
kinds of games in order to prioritize
your from anyone ok so the Lucas kind of
taken planet over to you know stream lee
high level are you familiar with the san
jose question games here and those for
two or three years running all right
what Luke will do is as he's got
actually like dozens of these games but
he'll go in and he'll you know for
example let's say he goes into apple and
and they're living in the next version
of the iphone there are all these
stakeholder constituencies writers this
marketing there's key way there's
hardware def there's hardware chest
there's software dev software testing
cetera right and they all have a
different view of the backlog right so
they're all they all want to prioritize
this different so he'll go away that
goes shirt size the backlog right small
medium large okay and then he'll get
representatives of each stakeholder
community to the table and they'll give
them anonymity but nobody gets enough
money to buy all the features they won
so now they have to horse-trade and what
happens as a result of this horse
trading is a a picture of the collective
wisdom emergence and it's almost always
surprising and it's almost always better
than anyone individuals Gessler
except for maybe Steve Jobs there's
something like ah but so so this is a
kind of game that it's a you know taps
into something that is actually really
fundamental right if you look at the
basis of democracy debates that
democracy is that the collective wisdom
is somehow superior to individuals
that's what we buy 89th indoors and so
so luke and I looked at his games we
looked at the state of the internet we
said look you know it's very very clear
that we have all of the communication
infrastructure to begin to have a wider
range of ways of getting at the
collective wisdom so why don't we what
we missed what we're missing is the
social technology Robert's Rules of
Order zat many social technology
holdings and very social technology
right we need a wider range of social
technology to to exploit the
communication infrastructure and
Giddings are a really good idea so we
were looking at putting his games online
at internet skated right and now and
then we ran smack into a problem and the
problem was identity so let's say that
there's this contentious issue like gay
marriage or health care reform right and
you want them sorry I live in Washington
State I said one of my senators category
okay and let's say patty Murray wants to
run a feature or health care reform by
the way we actually did is in Washington
and so yeah and then there's kind of two
sides to this internet scale on the one
hand patty Murray is not going to look
at the data if she knows that reality is
a bunch of RNC or E&C boss that are
standing the system she needs to have
some guarantee that the data that she's
looking at is her register
washington builders okay now the flip
side of that is that the voters might
not participate if they feel like
they're going to have unwanted attention
as a result of revealing their opinions
at that level of detail in the gameplay
okay so you got this tension you know
and there's there's there's facts about
personally identifiable information the
bar is very low so there really is a
tension here and so I have a I'm working
with a group of people who and I kind of
pre saves this before who are interested
in being able to have control over the
quality of identity you don't need to
know exactly who I am you need to know
that what I represent or what I claim to
represent is verifiable according to
some source that you trust and that's it
with respect to a particular
conversation so that when we talk about
agents that's actually what we need is
this little group of posts that are
working on this problem and that's why
it was so important to us not to have a
central server essential store central
control of the network X as motivated as
architecture that makes it all right so
so then the next step and all of this is
to note that and by the way everything
are saying I was not right logical a log
exclude middle the math is driving the
design hi calculus the math is driving
the design this next step in the design
the maddest argument society all you
have to do is go look at the 20-plus
years of research and security and
protocols and see how this design
sure all's out of things like any orders
work of the spy calculus and Martina
bodies work on provera or privilege a
smirk on prepare all of these things are
coming from the man okay so what we do
is to say that a challenge so what we
talked about remember we talked about
collection and location the collection
is actually our channel and a connection
between two agents of the internet is
now a compare a chance 14 Martin to
Eugene where we go the other from you
james park ok and a mind that the IV's
arrows are two collections just just as
in our other diagram right so when I so
in a process that is working on Martin's
behalf the asian to the internet is
listening or data from Eugene right
that's the Gant operation so there's a
for comprehension in its read somewhere
that for confirmation of that thread is
listening on this chick on this channel
likewise there's another for
comprehension if you g is listening for
something from market is important
operation listening on that chain so
does that make sense we're associating
channels with collections but remember
what I said the collections are actually
distributed over the Internet ok so let
me try to make this a little bit more
flesh out oh just before I run the demo
so let's say that we wanted to for one
agent to to be introduced to another
asian that turns into a for
comprehension which is looking for
introduction requests at a given channel
location right and then based on what it
receives let's say
except in truth except and accept it
will confirm or deny you know so this is
a way to implement two-phase commit for
example which is exactly what would be
necessary if you want mutual agreement
to establish a channel to be two hardest
I want to show you the code for this
this is like a little tiny fragment i
will show you the real code for this so
in general this is the kind of code that
we have developers writing and by the
way i'm also interested the sociological
process of this right like trying to get
these ideas across I've been trying to
get these ideas across are better than
20 years so these ideas are the heart of
Microsoft's this stock process
orchestration for example and and each
time each iteration of this sub I look
at I have to look at when I package this
stuff up what's the skill level of the
developer necessary to consume it so
what we found was I was able to give
this time to dsl to Java developers and
they weren't able to be building
distributed applications and weeks right
so I had a job developers who didn't
have a lot of castruccio application
experience writing the Striga television
this is not why i say twitter storm
where the topology is much more face the
publishing here's to finding a label
just like TCP IP service come up service
to them okay so we have we have we have
Java developers without a whole lot of
experience being able to build
applications like the one I'm about to
show you in meet now the other thing
that we're just about to bring online I
just want to practice this a little bit
is some scallop annotations I have a
have a contractor who is hoarding Lewis
high races spatial logic model checker
which allows one to check properties
against code now in this case the code
is my calculus code and the properties
are what are called behavioral types the
cool thing about behavioral types is
that when developers so here we're
getting developers and annotations rich
people be fed to the Scala and as a part
of Scotland either pipeline it will
check that just the skeleton code we
can't look at all the Scala code only be
coded actually in the dsl can be checked
against these annotations we can check
for deadlock freedom we can check for
information leakage so that's that's
what's about to come online so let's
take a look at these in real life hang
on a second so this application is a
little bit different and even some ways
it's not even as feature rich is
LinkedIn we just launched in april but
the principal idea is that it functions
in much the same way as LinkedIn accept
that and it's built on top of this this
architecture but businesses can pick up
their data and go and still be part of
the network there's no centralized
anything so at this moment I up to this
moment I didn't think about plugging
portunity but perhaps the best thing to
do is to go play with it seeing actually
a field for I'm not the best person to
demo opportunity but I work with the
team on the architecture and wrote a lot
of the code for ktv but I'm really not
the best opportunity that guy just just
realizing that now but one of the things
that that we have is the ability to
search and to search the social graph
okay and we've had this strong the
beginning so I can well let's see what
happens if I just as I put nothing in
here I guess I did everything that I can
see in two degrees
operation oh so now let's see how about
the moona software something engineering
okay this all this only one business
within two to three separation for me
that is looking for software I can item
here's a little connect icon so through
my connections I can ask for referrals
to be connected to cycling t'en right
except that now this goes through the
kind of introduction protocol that I was
showing you before right so that means
it's completely distributed I don't have
to hit the same resource all right so
that's a that's a half-ass demonstration
of virginity please go take a look at it
and play with it and really what we're
doing is we're looking for engagement so
if you did you play with it you say you
know I'm not getting it or this doesn't
make sense send us feedback let us know
because this is definitely confidence
this is one level of a bleep every week
we liked it like they have some devil
yeah can you call me what's the gate
convenient or in a taxi but why would
you collect education from various
networks so I could we write that to be
red and a blue networks bottom to top of
each other BBY i hope that again so who
asked for the mechanism for David money
collected if they can't who wants to
create right right sometimes having two
different networks BSF large network
know so the zoo every party that
interest here because this is all about
trusted business connections they go
through a fairly significant social
process for updates so the data that's
collected is collected initially through
a face-to-face injured see if you are
actually the valid and trust
business representative of such a
business and then the business provides
that the true and the intake process so
that's mature firm answer your question
he definitely explaining business value
of it but internal enhancing by which
collectively day one technology yeah it
progresses like you you sure got a blue
network near right network yes and
improve or you suggested that your wife
the only be for them to them does this
relate to this demo it does actually so
for example of right here this screen is
connected to a que vivir that is the
only place which talks both to you I and
today the data the data network is its
own network of DVDs so there's a soul
set that there's only one and those hey
bebes can also talk just you know
specialized atvs for business functions
for example running a introduction
protocol but this thing is going the
forms here talk through HTTP to a server
which has access to the data network but
is nominated so it's already that
architecture is is in play so we can we
can for example sever this link and know
that the data is secure I can't eat into
the data because you no longer have a
way I the whole network is isolated so
by maintaining a metadata repository
metadata repository okay you're able to
happen to that you connect book that
actually compromised each other every
maybe metadata let's take that one ola
because this isn't really meditative
right
is this literally just the fact that
when programmers are building these
things they're only mechanism for
personal they don't know whether what
they're accessing is local or remote so
we completely eliminated or merge
network access to local search access
they use the same for comprehensions for
both right and then what we do is the
mean fiber steps control is knowing
which collection you're going is
collection where a collection is really
a cop you know what you were calling a
cluster of those yes is the idea the
business they can do yet so they can
burn it off to a trusted hosting
provider or they run it themselves that
so painters cross the individual agent
works where we're so very much in the
beginnings of n so this is the facebook
like this long man and say you know in
summary what were what we've been
motivated by is bringing together a kind
of multi-dimensional solution right so
we've got people we've got a team of
people who are paying attention to the
mat I'm not going to buy intuitive the
math doesn't work out by and through the
design has certain properties that
relate to the requirements we also have
people working on them and paying
attention to the requirements from the
point of view of the market an army of
the market right now is that personal
data is being harvested you know your
data is worth billions and billions of
dollars and you're giving it away for
free you're also getting into parties
that maybe you really don't want to be
giving into and so there seems to be a
real need to be able to
to manage your own data in a distributed
fashion where you can have assurances
about the quality of the information
exchange all right so we have people
paying attention to that and we also
have people paying attention to the
applications application domains which
will help disseminate the ideas because
you know this like no my mom doesn't
care about the violence right when she
cares about is that she you know in her
and her practice her corporate booking
agents that she can share information in
a manner that helps her business it
helps the businesses that she goes so
we're looking at applications like
portunity which will make sense to
people so they can begin to move into
this world so those are the kind of
three three dimensions that we're
looking at and each one of those
actually really expands and and the
fourth thing is we're trying to make
sure we have some fun we're trying to
make sure that not only is a significant
and meaningful but it is it's a good
time that we all we all engage each
other with a kind of light heart and
with you know with a sense of glue glue
right I mean one of the one of the
things I was completely just head up at
off site to the extreme coding session
of the Denver and there wasn't thing I
said was I'm just trying to create a
company I'm trying to create good
company fellowship that's what this
technology is about being of enabling
the potential for connection without a
lot of people spying on those
connections all right so I'm going to
leave it there we go deeper in
individual conversations any questions
before I go on cool oh yes f it's on get
up you can grab it that's what
portunities that's what idea and then
the individual agent will
into production I can't give any days
but soon yeah yeah please you know I I
test what they need to return to
apologize the code sucks i want to go
clean it up that's why we're talking
about now is to get bright people
engaged in the code to put more energy
thanks very much the other questions
whoo all right thank you very much